هذه كبرى محطاتي تكرير النفط في اندونيسيا
في شيلات شاب على الساحل الجنوبي الغربي
لجزيره جاوه حيث يجري تكرير النفط
المستورد من الدول العربيه وحتى تتحول
المحطه نحو الطاقه الخضراء فان الطريقه ما
زال طويله كانت بدايته ان اطلقت شركه
برتامينا الاندونيسيه للنفط مشروع انتاج
الديزل من زيت النخي
على الساحل الشمالي الغربي لجزيره جاوا
حيث استهل خبراء اندونيسيون ويابانيون
قبيله قمه العشرين تطبيقه تقنيه لالتقاط
الكربون لرفع انتاجيه حقول النفط والغاز
القديمه وخفض الانبعاثات
والله ثاني اكسيد الكربون من النفايات لكن
بتطبيق هذه التقنيه نستفيد منه لرفع تجيه
النفط والغاز ما بين 30 و40% مع اعاده حقن
ثاني اكسيد الكربون في باطن ونحن نعلم ان
انتاج اندونيسيا منه سيصل الى ذروته عام
في اوكرانيا مثلا رفعت الطلب الاوروبيه
على فحم اندونيسيا لتوليد الكهرباء وهي
اكبر مصدري الفحم في العالم والثالثه
انتاج له معتبر انتكاسه بيئيه
جرائم
في توليد الطاقه
وحتى لو لم تستكشف مناجم فحم جديده لدينا
فانما يستخرج يكفي اندونيسيا لنحو 65 عاما
ولهذا يزعم بان الوقود الاحفوري يظل
الارخص
تغيير لمصدر الطاقه فهناك عواقب وكلفه
باهظه تتعلق بالايدي العامله في محطات
تعتمد الفحم كالتي في محافظه وهي الاقدم
في اندونيسيا اضافه الى تداعيات اغلاق
مناجم الفحم وتكاليف تشييد منظومه طاقه
بديله
تواجه الدول الناميه صعوبات ماليه في
سعيها لتغيير مصادر الطاقه فمن اجل ان
تغلق دوله كي اندونيسيا كل محطات توليد
الكهرباء من الفحم كهذه المحطه ستحتاج
لسبعه وثلاثين مليار دولار واكثر من 300
مليار اخرى لتاسيسي منظومه بديله لتوليد
واستهلاك مصادر الطاقه المتجدده
في جزيره تجاول اندونيسيه